relatives of nearly 1200 jillians who
were never seen again after they were
detained nearly 50 years ago by agents
of Chile's former military dictatorship
were invited to the presidential Palace
for a very special event
among them 48 year old Christian
Martinez he was still a baby in 1975
when his father left the house to meet
another member of the clandestine
left-wing organization that he belonged
to
when he arrived at the designated Corner
the agents were waiting had been
betrayed by a comrade who'd broken under
torture my father managed to convince
them to drop me off at my grandparents
house nearby before taking him away
we never saw him again
Martinez has been trying to put the
pieces together ever since his mother
fled to France with her two children who
became friends with the children of
another exiled couple
it was only when Martinez returned to
Chile as an adult that he discovered
that his friend's father was the one who
had betrayed his
when we met two years ago I told them I
can't hate you I think that you your
family and my family are all victims of
that historic period our country lived
through
perhaps none have suffered more than the
friends and families of the missing who
have been carrying out a painful lonely
and frustrating search for their missing
loved ones for nearly five decades now
for the first time since Chile's return
to democracy current president Gabrielle
borage has announced a plan to search
for the remains of the more than 1100
people who disappeared it entails More
Money More technology more science but
above all more political will for the
Chilean state to take responsibility for
what happened
but for the families of the Disappeared
there's a mixture of Hope and skepticism
more than two decades ago the presumed
remains of political prisoners were dug
up in this hill
in a shocking report on National
Television earlier this month it was
revealed that they'd been put in
cardboard boxes unidentified and
forgotten in official forensic centers
until now
our mothers our widows have passed
without getting answers so we say this
plan is too late we hope the state's
negligence will end now
that is what the president is promising
that after nearly half a century at
least some may at last be able to bury
their dead to see a human Al Jazeera
Santiago
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera